vmx is a fast-paced sport from the time
that that gate drops until you cross the
finish line you're always thinking about
your next move as long as I can keep
those two wheels on the ground I'm gonna
be out there on that track
[Music]
my name is Kitty West an hour and I am
70 years old I am the oldest female BMX
racer in the United States I have been
involved in the sport of BMX racing as a
racer for 30 years now now I love
challenges and this was just another
challenge when I began racing BMX
there was no women's cruiser class I
worked with our sanctioning bodies and
talked about the fact that women want to
be a part of this
we now have thousands of women and girls
who race throughout the country over
women 70 years young
Miss Kitty Western now are sitting in
that's race a lot more told
[Music]
throughout each year I will do anywhere
from 25 to 30 races and quite often I'm
racing much much younger women I
finished seventh in the world in the 45
and over women's cruiser class I was the
oldest female to participate in the UCI
BMX world is just unbelievable this can
be a dangerous sport in 1993 I was
involved in an accident where after
falling off of my bike I broke my neck I
was told that I might not be able to
walk again but within six months I was
back to racing and I have continued to
be involved in the spirit you know
people have asked me how long do I plan
to keep racing BMX bikes I tell people
age is nothing but a number and I
seriously mean that every time I get out
on that track I win and it's not about
crossing 1st 2nd or 3rd but it's about
having fun
it's about the enjoyment of being with
others who really enjoy this sport I
want to continue to enjoy life
and this is a part of my life
[Music]